[Inaudible].
For years, he was the investor most feared by wall street executives,
a tough guy with a strong inflexible character and a good head for business.
Over time. Carl Icahn has become one of the most important investors in history.
Someone who grew up in Queens in a middle-class family,
who went to a public school yet has managed to achieve one of the 80 greatest
fortunes in the world. To give you an idea,
according to Forbes his net worth his wealth exceeded the incredible figure of
$14 billion. At the time of making this video,
you don't have to look any further than his own Twitter accounts to see how he
describes himself.
Some people get rich studying artificial intelligence. Me,
I make money studying natural stupidity.
Don't tell me that it's not a really clear statement of intent,
but you know what? It's not just a matter of money with an icon,
but above all a matter of philosophy and style,
his tough Gliffy may have waned a bit these days, but for a long time,
icon was known for his aggressive way of operating in the markets.
We're talking about an activist investor who has never had any qualms,
even dismantling entire companies. If for him,
that was the best way to manage capital and make a profit.
This was a strategy or way of working that as you can imagine,
there's never made him a lot of friends,
but one that has made him a source of inspiration for the media and Hollywood
directors. For example,
time magazine defined him as the real Hoff of wall street and Michael Douglas
and Richard Gere have acknowledged that the roles of Gordon gecko in the film
wall street and Edward Lewis in pretty woman were heavily influenced by this
real life investor. And look,
perhaps the best example of how good icon was,
is by looking at his handling of trans world airlines for decades.
One of the most important airlines in the United States in 1985 icon took
control of this airline taking on a huge debt in the project.
Over the next few years,
he methodically sold assets of this company to get the funds he needed to return
the money that he had borrowed an operation.
Very similar to the one that Gordon gecko orchestrated in the 1987 film wall
street Friends. He may not be so well-known,
but for the last 20 years,
Carl Icahn has not only managed to beat the market repeatedly,
but his profitability has been far superior than even Warren Buffett himself.
But who is Carl Icahn? Really? How did he get into the world of markets?
How did he make his fortune?
What investment style did this already legendary investor use with this new
video in the series that we are producing in conjunction with value score will
tell you, listen up the road to start them.
Despite.
Being born into a family without any great luxuries icon was able to attend and
graduate from the prestigious Princeton university.
I had no food or place to sleep,
but in the summer I worked as a maintenance guy at some beach huts on long
Island. I bought large amounts of AEs to sell to the customers hot days.
And at night I played poker with the owners. I bought three books,
studied the games and cleaned them out. Carl Icahn.
Well, it doesn't seem like a bad start. Does it?
Well yet it wasn't until after graduating from Princeton spending two years in
medical school and enlisting in the military icon finally began his career on
wall street, but let's move on because the story,
the real story begins in 1975
that's year icon was already self-employed with his right-hand man,
Alfred Kingsley at the time,
both focused on their efforts on conducting arbitration operations are ye
simultaneously buying and selling an asset that is traded in two or more markets
at different prices. Well, that's the theory, at least as you can imagine,
the practice is usually a little more complex.
Icon and his partner specialized in what is known as convertible arbitration,
IE opening short or long positions in shares and convertible securities of the
same companies. Simultaneously.
The idea was to take advantage of the small differences that for different
reasons could be recorded in the market. However,
they soon expanded their range to closed investment funds. In these cases,
Eikon and his partner invested in the funds by buying their States at a discount
whilst financing those transactions by short-selling a stock portfolio
equivalent to the funds themselves.
The goal was to take advantage of the discount, the funds hat.
And right here is when the two partners ask themselves a question,
how could they make the funds close their value gap relative to the stocks they
had in their portfolios? Well,
it's at this very moment that Eikon and Kingsley started behaving like activist
investors. Once they establish their position,
they began to pressure the fund managers to liquidate them.
I E sell all the shares and distribute the money to the funds participants this
way, Eikon and his partner could get remarkable profits in a very short time.
This strategy worked, but the number of funds with which they could carry out,
these operations were limited. And that led them to a new thought.
If we can be activists in a closed and undervalued investment fund,
why can't we be activists in a corporation with undervalued assets,
Alfred Kingsley.
That's the new strategy they put into place in 1975.
And their timing was also ideal. You see, after a decade of stagflation,
a crisis in the oil market and a languishing economy,
1974 was the worst year in North American markets. Since the great depression,
since the peak of 1973,
the us stock exchange has lost 45% of its value.
This caused many shares to be clearly undervalued with trading levels.
Well below the asset value itself.
In our view,
the elements of today's economic environment have been uniquely combined to
create great benefit opportunities with relatively little risk,
the real or liquidation value of many us companies has increased markedly in
recent years. However, and this is what is interesting.
It has not been fully reflected in the market value of the shares,
Carl Icahn and an investor's memo.
Now how I con choose his investments,
what was the method that pushed him to the top of the investment world? Well.
The corporate assault.
Our protagonist in this video made his fortune as something like a corporate
Raider.
He would buy a major stake in a company and then try to force management to make
certain decisions that will cause the share price to increase.
This used all kinds of strategies, media pressure,
active searches for potential buyers, disinvestment plans, power struggles,
et cetera. Take a look at this.
From our.
Perspective,
we believe the great profits can be made by taking a long positions in
undervalued actions and then trying to control the fates of companies,
but the following actions, Hey,
trying to convince management to liquidate or sell the company to a white
Knight, be provoking a power struggle,
see making a purchase offer D reselling our position to the company.
This.
Is what writer Mark Stevens called the icon manifesto.
As you can see in the eyes of this investor,
what are the biggest difficulties facing shareholders is the one known as the
agency problem, a well-known problem in financial theory,
for those of you who don't know what it means,
it's that the managers of the companies usually have different objectives than
the shareholders in that the managers do not know much about maximizing the
value for the land.
[Inaudible].
Leading activism campaigns.
If you're strong enough was something that could generate significant returns.
Of course, before we get carried away in this excitement of board room,
powerplays keep in mind that these kinds of campaigns also had a much more
controversial site.
Many of these activism operations ended with a practice that is now banned.
It was known as green male or business black male, uh,
financial practice consisting of the following after unleashing a power struggle
and a media campaign for control of the company,
e-comm negotiated the sale of its shares to the company itself in exchange for a
generous premium.
In this way,
the executives managed to save their heads and got to the annoying icon out of
their way. Of course, those who paid the price,
where the rest of the shareholders.
We.
Are talking about the practice that Warren Buffett himself came to describe as
hateful and disgusting of course, to be fair.
The fact that like Tom was able to close numerous such agreements,
says very little of the integrity of the managers themselves.
Of course not all operations ended this way. One of the best known examples.
And at the same time,
one of the first operations that made a name for this investor was his handling
of the Tappan stove company,
a manufacturer of ovens and stoves that was going for a rough patch by Collin
gradually bought a larger and larger stake. And when he had enough weight,
you got to seat on the board of directors.
And from there he promoted the sale of non-strategic assets and tried by all
means possible to find a buyer for the company.
So can you guess how it all ended? Well, look,
I can't began investing in 1977 when the shares were traded at around
$8 just two years later. And thanks in large parts to icons, maneuvers,
Belgian manufacturer,
and lecturer Luxe ended up paying $18 for each share that is he more than
doubled his investment in just over two years?
I don't think that this was an isolated case in the table below.
You can see some of his most lucrative options,
The height of his career in the 1980s,
I can control billions in capital and caused real dread.
Even among executives of the large corporations in the American stocks,
Campaigns have continued up to this day. For example, in 2019,
he launched a public campaign against the board of directors of Occidental
petroleum for an agreement that they had reached with Warren buffet.
Another well-known recent example was his role in pressuring Apple to launch
what may have been the largest share, buy back program in history.
It made no sense to this investor that the Cupertino based company should
accumulate tens and tens of billions of dollars a year.
Cash.
One question that comes up is,
but how does he decide in which companies to invest well,
although he's not exactly known for being a value investor.
The truth is that if we study everything on a case by case basis,
icon has almost always followed Benjamin Graham's thesis.
The majority of his operations have centered on companies that for various
reasons seems to be trading at a huge discount with respect to their intrinsic
value.
His role was then to drive enough corporate changes for that hidden value to
emerge, even if it meant liquidating the company itself.
And the idea that Graham,
the father of value investing himself defended on numerous occasions.
Anyway, this story.
Of call icon, one of the great investors of all time, an atypical investor,
who of course has also made huge mistakes.
Some as well-known as blockbuster Yahoo or more recently,
herps a company that we covered not long ago in this video.
And that has cost this investor more than 1.5 billion.
I really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
this channel is possible because of patriarchy and that will patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you, then.
[Inaudible].